all right
Mrs Zulu caswelletini takes over the
throne in a traditional ceremony at the
Royal crawl in nongoma at the ceremony
in August the death of his father
Goodwill's relatini was also announced
and misizulu was introduced to his
ancestors in line with spiritual beliefs
we asked him
I pledge to the Zulu nation that I will
Traverse a truthful Journey an upright
journey and a journey that is blessed by
God and our ancestors I promise to be
with you through thick and thin
foreign
followed a family battle with two other
family members contesting the throne
saying Mrs Zulu is not the rightful heir
but their Court challenges failed now
mississulu is to be crowned in a
government-led ceremony in the first
coronation of the Zulu King in more than
half a century
rehearsals have been in full swing
throughout the week
South Africa is a constitutional
democracy but for many here culture and
tradition are just as important as
custodial of the Zulu Nation the
coronation of the new King by the
government recognizes both his role and
influence and for supporters it's a
welcome balance between the old and the
new
traditional Zulu Kings usually have a
little political power but enjoy immense
social influence in Zulu we say the king
is regarded as
it means his authority goes because
there is no lie coming out of his mouth
so what he says is the truth
because it is believed that once he's
introduced to the former Kings he gains
that powers those powers to command
authority to the people through a trust
established at the end of Apartheid in
South Africa in the early 1990s King
Mississippi Zulu is one of the largest
landowners in the world those living on
the land have to pay rent
some have taken the monarchy to court to
get more rights to land they consider
their own
but while the young king has some
challenges ahead his coronation is a day
of celebration for the Zulu people
famide Al Jazeera Durban